[Music]  no two kids pull the ultimate prank on  their principal in Captain Underpants is  it okay that I'm kind of loving this I  will set you free because there was  sacred duty to defend the one Wonder  Woman stars gal gadot as amazon princess  who must help save the world  de la pucelle examine repeaters de  Mestre yes I received a chemical on del  apoyo in three idiotas three guys go on  a search for their long-lost college  buddy who disappeared on graduation day  see with hot in theaters with this  week's anticipation so what's your  weekend to get going to be let us know  by commenting see you next time on  weekend ticket  [Music]